all right sticking with football now how
about this turn our attention to super
bowl 56 kicking off in la sunday
afternoon between the rams and bengals
we now go to sophie stadium kevin martin
has been there all week kevin we know
the city has been rebuilt for this big
game but so have the la rams they have
turned themselves into a championship
team haven't they
well good evening chris and yeah exactly
you know what we say in vegas the rams
have put all their chips on the table
for this championship run and that's
exactly what we've seen in this roster
it's star-studded of course it started
with the trade matthew stafford the
quarterback and then they've traded for
sony michelle the former patriots
running back then onto von miller and
then the highly publicized trade of
elder beckham jr from the browns they
have it all on the table for this one
but it might work out because they are
just one win away from claiming the
super bowl
all right kevin now even though this
game is being held at the rams home
stadium at sofi they're actually going
to be the away team aren't they
yeah exactly the nfl just switches
between conferences every single year so
last year it was the nfc who was the
home team this year it's the afc the
bengals and they will be considered the
quote unquote home team on sunday for
super bowl 56 another thing that the
home team gets to do is pick the jersey
color the bengals are going with the
darks so the la rams will be playing in
the whites but that's actually good news
for la because out of the last 17 super
bowls the team wearing the white
uniforms have won 14 times so the rams
of course are trying to make it 15 out
of 18. reporting live outside of sofie
stadium kevin martin chris all right
thank you very much kevin we'll talk it
to you again tomorrow now we wait for
the coin flip it's been three tails in a
row do you go for heads or tails
big question we'll be right back